don't trust the cloud and it's good it
looks like we are live well welcome
everybody to the end of the impossible
podcast and this week I'm joined by a
very special guest which is Darren lip
ami who's a professor of nano
engineering is that the is that the
actual title that's that's the title
that's the name of the department also
Chemical Engineering but I'm a trained
chemist so we cover a lot of bases yeah
yeah alright I thought I'd be like a
whole bunch of Smurfs sized engineers
running around there but but we'll get
into what it actually means to be a nano
engineer in just a bit I want to read I
want to read Darren's Darren's bio here
and let's start if I can find it here
I believe there is so Darren and I
actually met you know through a strange
series of events that seems like a
distant memory but it was really only
supposed to take place a few months ago
which is the Kyoto Prize ceremony in San
Diego that was to take place takes place
annually or has for the last couple of
decades both in Kyoto Japan and in San
Diego of all places because I think
Kyocera corporation has their US
headquarters here in San Diego and
they've given out awards there for 20 or
30 years and the sciences and the
technology branches of technology and
engineering and also in the arts it's a
wonderful organization I've been
involved with tangentially for several
years but Darren and I were paired as
hosts sort of caretakers I don't know
fixers is the right word Darren I'm not
sure how to say it but we were hosting
the three laureates this year in and in
the sciences it was doctor professor Jim
Gunn of the Princeton University and
Darren was - host was it was Chang
they'll be Nick Tong Chang - Tom yeah so
we'll talk a little bit perhaps we have
time but let me just first introduce
Darren Darren earned his undergraduate
degree in chemistry from Boston
University and his PhD from the
department of chemistry and chemical
biology at a at Harvard University in
June 20
at Harvard he worked in a laboratory
professor George Whitesides in the areas
of materials chemistry nano fabrication
including soft lithography and nano
skivvy aim which I don't know what nano
skiving has a bit of a funny etymology
but we can get into that or not yeah I
have any relation to persica bytes no
but but skiving itself is a british
english word that means slacking off so
we came up with the word and then
published it before realizing that it
was you know nano skiving was slacking
off in a very small way he was also a
postdoctoral fellow at Stanford
University and chemical engineering he
has a very interesting fork in his
career at least or partially and one
branch of his wavefunction he earned a
certificate the so called mini MBA from
Stanford University Graduate School of
Business I think that's quite
spectacular hopefully we can get into
that it's now called Stanford ignite and
he joined UCSD in 2012 as a professor in
the Department of nano engineering which
is part of the Jacobs School of
Engineering today an honor I couldn't
find any UCSD shirts to wear in my in my
hamper I didn't want to pull one out so
I pulled out a Padres jersey in honor of
the fact that maybe this will come out
soon when the Padres season is set to
resume and as I always say even in a
kovat shortened season I like to wear it
and support them in the first week of
the season before they're mathematically
eliminated and so far that's brought me
good luck anyway Darrin won't lengthy
introduction to a very impressive I
won't say young men because you're
you're so accomplished I'll just say
it's very impressive to have you as a
colleague and as a friend didn't have
you as a guest on the into the
impossible podcast today we're going to
talk about your podcast though so tell
us a little bit more if you like about
some of the stuff you do outside of your
phenomenal teaching and coursework that
you put online on your youtube channel
there and lipoma believe that's your
youtube handle tell us what else you're
up to these days in this era of code
so moving into the digital presentation
space was always something that I was
interested in when I was a little kid I
got a it's called a fisher-price pxl mm
video camera which shot about 11 minutes
of a black-and-white video per side of a
an audio tape so very high data rate
that's why you couldn't get very much on
there but you know we didn't have the
money for a standalone VHS recorder so
this is what I used and then you know
various iterations of VHS compact
camcorders later
you know I basically just made my
stuffed animals act out scenes from Star
Wars and then we had a TV show that I
produced called the yummy Trek which was
a parody of Star Trek and that kind of
got me through high school and then I
kind of abandoned the the performance
sort of aspects of nerdiness for a while
until I developed all of this this
coursework and I wanted to put it online
and there are a few reasons that I
wanted to put it online one of which is
to sort of engage with the active
learning or flipped classroom
methodology of teaching and what that
allowed me to do was to assign lectures
as pre-recorded material and then sort
of transform the the class period into a
variety hour where we did where we would
do design problems and questions and and
and group activities and and modern
applications of the material around the
same time this is 2017 I was asked to
organize a discussion series for grad
students and postdocs in the engineering
school on professional development and I
was very excited to take on this role
because it got me through it I was able
to make connections with people in
industry and and other and and law and
and other aspects of the business and
professional world
to bring them in and give talks to the
to the students however there were a lot
of topics for which I couldn't find
speakers and I ended up giving those
talks myself and because I was doing the
recording I bought all this recording
equipment for teaching I ended up
recording all of those and I ended at
the back so it's a-you know so many
people have asked me for the recording
equipment and I just send them my Amazon
order order page but it's it's you know
a not not quite pro model 4k camera and
and so I ended up with about 20 of these
lectures and they took an enormous
amount of time to prepare the slides and
in what I was going to say and how I was
going to respond to questions and those
so I put all of those on YouTube as well
and some of those are some of my most
you know more popular than the course
content and I was also getting requests
for audio versions it kind of made me
feel bad at first because I spent all
this time making the visuals and the
slides but it turns out if you close
your eyes it's basically the same you
know information that's on the screen
just coming out of my mouth so actually
just a few weeks ago I started a podcast
where I was at first just taking the
audio versions of some of these talks
and putting them on the podcast and
since then I've started to make some
some new content and then sort of have
across cross-pollination between the
YouTube channel and the podcast podcast
is called molecular podcasting with
Darren Lupo me yeah so many things to
talk about first do you feel like the
lectures the kind of non-scientific but
incredibly vital for the actual
successful ship or whatever Homer
Simpson would call it is is added to
your teaching abilities has it augmented
them as it a compliment is it something
that anybody can do or or something
unique because you have this passion
since by your own admission since you're
a kid you love to be an on-camera
I think recording the videos about
professional topics has made me as made
me consider aspects of of professional
professionalism how ideas are generated
how to write effectively that maybe in
my everyday life as an academic I
wouldn't really have a reason to be self
reflective about these things so it
really takes a good you know couple of
days of quite intensive study and you
know not quite meditation on these these
topics to to develop an appreciation for
how to convey them to others and how
through the pinna process how do I
convey them to yourself and how to how
to incorporate some of the tips and
tricks into your own work I think
anybody anybody could do it I think that
there are it takes a certain amount of
[Music]
comfort with exposure maybe that putting
all of your materials and even quite
quite personal thoughts online for
everybody to see it takes it takes some
of that so I think everyone could do it
I don't think everyone is inclined to do
it how did you come up with the name
molecular podcasting and the cover
artwork for the podcast so the cover
artwork is was is a molecular dynamic
simulation by one of my former students
Sam root who's now a postdoc at Harvard
he he has credit in my in my podcast
description um the name molecular
podcasting came from be from really two
sources one I'm a chemist and I feel a
strong affinity to chemistry and
molecules and there aren't too many
there aren't compared to your own field
and biology there aren't that many high
profile chemists doing outreach work and
I'm not going to call myself high
profile but I am doing outreach work and
there is there is
there's a lot of outreach in the
chemical community I don't want to
offend anybody but what I really mean is
there's no equivalent of a Carl Sagan
not to compare myself to Carl Sagan I
think you know what I'm saying chemistry
I think that it's because I don't quite
know why this is Peter Peter Atkins the
physical chemist you know try to do some
of this with this book the second law
but it probably honestly never really
caught on
so that's one reason another is that
molecular in terms of you know mechanics
we think about continuum mechanics
versus molecular mechanics molecular
mechanics very small nano sized objects
that that are kind of the word molecular
might be associated with the middie
gritty and nuts and bolts of how things
actually get done and I think that's
what what differentiates my
popularization or my strategy toward
popularization compared to maybe some
other active scientists and that I'm
really talking about how does the
science get done kind of on the the the
proverbial molecular scale at that
granularity level yeah and actually I
was introduced to science my first
inspiration as a popular science author
was Isaac Asimov not his science fiction
books which I have to read
embarrassingly enough for a person who
hosts a podcast called into the
impossible based on arthur c clarke
famous phrases which we'll get into I
wanna ask you the three questions I
asked all my guests towards the very end
of our conversation but Isaac Asimov
books on science nonfiction chemistry
Adams the history of chemistry I
couldn't get enough of them and that was
sort of as a 10 or 12 year old take us
through your world line as we physicists
say you obviously I know your academic
pedigree I'm sorry went to such subpar
institutions all the way from undergrad
to graduate where'd you grow up what got
you into chemistry what got you into the
Nano world and where is your specific
research going and what what fascinates
you about this underworld
sure that's it's sort of the parallel
track to the schools and the degrees
first a little side note about Isaac
Asimov it was actually a professor at my
alma mater Boston University yeah yeah
and he was a he taught biochemistry at
one point when he became a famous writer
and he lost his or he gave up or lost or
whatever his his permanent position he
actually gave one lecture a year and one
of my roommates who had a whose father
is a dentist had him for a pre-med
dental biochemistry class so anyway
nice nice connection there and okay so
actually I'll go back Isaac Asimov is an
example of a trained chemist who is a
popularizer okay so I grew up in western
New York State and a town called Hilton
about 20 miles northwest of Rochester
and I got and it's it's hard to pinpoint
the moment I got into science I can tell
you the exact date that I got into like
Star Trek because I watched I was
watching this you know late night TV via
Phil the Fox affiliate that would run
the reruns and we just got our 486
family computer in 1993 and I know the
date that I started watching Star Trek's
because Star Trek because my sister's
kicked me off of the computer and when
you boot it up the computer and they
said that that you know the day that the
BIOS was set and everything was was
October 10th 1993 so that's the day that
I watched episode 29 operation
annihilate where Spock has this this
fried egg land on his back that injects
some tentacles into his body and then he
becomes blind and so on so that's the
episode that's the particular moment
Star Trek was hugely influential on me
Star Wars before that although it
doesn't quite have the same intellectual
intellectualism in terms of myth and
exposing a young kid to space flight and
warp speed and so on and bio-neural gel
packs and things that I'm thinking about
now and haptics and holodecks and stuff
you know that's that's that's there for
a while I thought I wanted to go into
medicine so I really enjoyed this show
on The Learning Channel when we were
kind of given an illicit cable
subscription at some point called trauma
life in the ER and I really like the
idea of trauma surgery
I liked the intensity of it or I thought
I did I went to I applied fairly broadly
I'm actually skipping a major part and
that's my interest in music particularly
the piano and the trombone my I was a
band geek in high school I applied to to
music school at Eastman and northwestern
for trombone kind of the two were the
best brass schools but I didn't get in
and and no offense to any of my my my
former music classmates I did not want
to teach though I wanted to be on stage
in an orchestra or an or an opera pit
and that's what I wanted to do but I
didn't get into any of the schools that
I wanted to for music however all of
those places I also apply it as a double
major to engineering and I didn't really
know what engineering was my favorite
subject in high school was chemistry so
I so I chose Chemical Engineering turns
out that Chemical Engineering has
basically nothing to do with with
chemistry because it's it's basically
all Continuum's stuff I can just hear
people yelling at their at their ear
buds right now but chemists
Chemical Engineering is intellectually
much more similar to mechanical
engineering than it is to chemistry
whereas it's it's fluid mechanics as
opposed to solid mechanics if you take
it to sort of the you know first
approximation but so the the other if
the school didn't have a chemical
engineering program I applied to
biomedical engineering or bioengineering
and for no other reason that in but that
it sounded cool and it had like the most
syllables so at Boston University I was
a bio biomedical engineering major for
a couple of weeks but my second year of
undergrad 9/11 happened and it made me
very I don't know skeptical or or
uninterested or actually disinterested
for a time in technology and the way and
and becoming part of some you know
technological machine and so I just want
because sorry to interrupt but you mean
because it might have some potential
application towards defense or warfare
is that what you mean because it felt
let me let me rephrase I think it's
because it felt too dry and and and non
not human facing right not nourishing of
that yeah humans okay I get exactly yeah
so I switched my major to anthropology
and radical I switched from physics to
mechanical engineering to astronomy to
physics so we will get will get narrow
but at first you know it's like the wave
form we get though so we went to it's a
switch to biological anthropology
because I was very interested in in in
behavioral biology and evolution and and
things like that my I had a fantastic I
read a fantastic book and my
introductions of biological anthropology
course called
Lucy's legacy by the primatologist Alice
Alice and jolly and in this book the
author has since passed away but she she
referenced an author named Leo Wilson
several times and Leo Wilson Edward o
Wilson a famous professor at Harvard and
and and curator of the the American or
the the Harvard Museum of Natural
History wrote the book sociobiology
which was along with a couple of other
books in the early 70s including The
Selfish Gene by Richard Dawkins sort of
introduced the idea of this no no no
maybe it's not introduced but popularize
this idea of the
connection between molecular evolution
and and biological adaptation and then
social behavior in in animals and the
last chapter and sociobiology was where
he he daringly applied the the the
concepts of sociobiology to human
behavior and that was hugely
controversial and there was this this
period of time where he was kind of
ostracized by the by by the academic
left as famously other people at Harvard
like Richard Lewontin and Stephen Jay
Gould and so anyway he he became you
wrote a follow-up book called on human
nature where he sort of doubled down and
then later on in his in his writing
career he became he wrote a book called
Concilium switch is about the the unity
of knowledge and the central theme of
the book is that is the deep
connectivity between all branches of
learning so really the only reason that
that chemistry and physics and biology
are considered even different
disciplines is because of historical
accidents you know where does where does
physical chemistry and in chemical
physics begin it's just a it's probably
a fuzzy boundary at best maybe it's even
a kind of productive boundary and if you
look all the way up through levels of
organization in science and human
learning you go from biology to
neuroscience to to psychology to
economics or sociology and and at which
point do the boundaries actually make
sense and one could argue that because
it's all historical accidents I mean the
reason that chemical engineering
departments exists is because is because
we're trying to process chemicals on a
large scale largely due to the needs of
the petroleum
industry but you know there are it's
it's very rare to find research in a
chemical engineering department that
could not happen be happening in in a
physics department or a chemistry
department or even a even in some cases
of biology department so there's so much
intermixing that once I was in once I
was an undergraduate I wanted to find a
way to combine these interests and I've
taken quite a garden path here thank you
for your for your patience so I was so
this was biological anthropology that
was my major but I had an excellent
teacher in in chemistry 102 John Strauss
who is a physical chemist sort of a
protein dynamicists and he he really he
took a lot of time one summer when I was
cleaning toilets for the office of
conference services at BU and I listened
to my CD walkman and then on my lunch
breaks I would read these books by Gould
and Wilson and Allison jolly and whoever
my hands-on and and he and I started to
develop this idea of an independent
concentration where I could take
whatever I wanted and then do some sort
of senior thesis at the end what I
eventually ended up doing though was
taking a little bit more of a of a
conventional route I changed my major to
biochemistry and then to straight-up
chemistry and then added a minor in
physics and then said okay we're not
going to spend a lot of intellectual
resources on this independent
concentration I'm just going to do that
stuff on the side and get a traditional
degree so around that time I got a
fellowship from the Beckman Scholars
program which provided summer funding
for two consecutive summers and one
academic year and I got to pick any any
professors lab so I chose Jim Panic who
is doing natural product total synthesis
so this is where a molecule is isolated
in this case from a bacterium that lives
in a sea sponge off the coast of Papua
New Guinea that had biological activity
against
against very dangerous fungal infections
that occur in hiv/aids patients as well
as as patients on chemotherapy and so
there wasn't a route to a lot of this
material they only recovered you know
less than a milligram from the from the
sponge so there's a lot of value in in
making and developing a synthetic route
to come up with with more of this
materials so with my graduate student
mentor Neal LAN Joel and I we we made
the compounds I think I can do the rest
in like in like less than a minute okay
I went to I went to grad school
originally to continue my interest in
inorganic chemistry but I found that I
was kind of burned out on the topic
quite honestly and I ended up joining
George Whitesides group because at the
time he had a project on the the
chemical origins of life so how do you
get how'd he get energy dissipating
self-replicating systems in in abiotic
conditions that project didn't really go
anywhere instead there was this other
project based on unconventional nano
fabrication of various structures really
it has everything to do with the the the
postdocs who were hired at the same time
as I came on and a grad student
Emily Weiss Ryan checky and Michael
Dickey who took me under their wing and
I learned really their craft from them
then when I did a postdoc at Stanford it
was to combine my interests in organic
chemistry with material science and
that's where I started to work on
stretchable bio-inspired electronics and
devices then when I started at UCSD the
idea was to combine
literally all of my interests in
building molecules from the ground up
for applications in devices that
interface with with biological systems
was quite a peregrination but my
apologies
very but very intriguing
that it's it's too bad you and I both
are you know New Yorkers and so we speak
pretty quickly so even even add 2x
multiplier on the YouTube or I'm on the
iPod you will still still be able to cut
it down but what users will find the
half speed as well that's right I like
to alternate between half and double
speed just to keep my brain active you
mentioned a lot it's clear to me we're
gonna have to have another conversation
about about specifics maybe we'll have a
separate conversation about these
academic issues I'll just say one thing
that it's clear you know as Soren
Kierkegaard said you know life must be
lived forwards but it could only be
understood looking backwards and now I
do have an understanding of why you are
you know sort of uniquely able to fuse
the very hard technical very scientific
aspects of cutting-edge research and
pedagogy as you do in your academic
playlist so to speak with this kind of I
always forget is your left brain right
brain I forget the other side of the
brain which deals with the so called
soft or interpersonal attributes of the
of the human intellect and and that
simultaneously through you they can both
find a safe a safe purchase and and that
is a testimony to the work that you
presumably put in and you're one of your
many undergraduate majors and and and
your curiosity you know I picked up a
lot of things there that that you've an
avid reader I think that you're actually
curious intellectually and that your
curiosity isn't just restricted and I
don't mean this pejoratively but we both
know people that only focus on what they
do and they're they could be tops in the
field of what they do but but in terms
of a more broader panorama of the big
picture of science the the background
that you've outlined seems to very
naturally suit you to be in a position
to communicate these vital lessons to
our students and some of those lessons
are really never taught in one of your
lectures I think I think it's a good
title maybe you should use it for your
book but it's called how to win friends
and influence people already the
title of a very popular book Oh too bad
yeah
but the but the but that in that lecture
you give an overview of how how people
perceive the role in the place of a
scientist and the way that or an
engineer and how he or she should
orchestrate their balance between
technical ability and interpersonal
abilities and those can include
networking public speaking you know
listening skills communication skills
and versus the pure technical skills
which seem a lot easier and seem a lot
more important but most scientists and
engineers believe that that is the
number one thing is to be technically
competent in reality it's you present in
your in a wonderful pie chart I believe
is is the exact you know complement of
that structure in other words it's
basically two thirds or maybe three to
one
you know ratio between between the
interpersonal skills and network
networking etc two technical skills now
why what do you make of that I have a I
have a certain theory about that but I
want to segue into academia right now by
asking you that why do you think that a
the perception is exactly inverted and B
why do you think it is that to be a
successful engineer it really benefits
you to work on things outside of
chemical engineering I mean if you had
to put it that it would be it would sort
of replace most your tokens on the soft
skills so to speak it's it's very
interesting the there's an idea I think
perpetuated by caricatures like Sheldon
from from the Big Bang Theory or Martin
prince from The Simpsons
that these these uber intellectuals you
know are the scientists and are the
scientific leaders I would I would say
that the the scientific leader is not
necessarily always in fact in my
experience rarely the smartest person in
the room on kind of a raw intellectual
horsepower however you want to you want
to say that you know I have I have
students who who can do so
more than I can you know with a with a
theory or building a building
computational algorithm to calculate
some property the I think the it's
important to have a meta appreciation
for one's own skills and what one brings
to the table there was a there was a an
interview with the chef Alton Brown on a
show the the big idea with Donny Deutsch
that appeared I think sometime in the
late 2000s when that show was still it
was still a thing I don't know if it is
an Elton Brown said you know ultimately
or you're selling yourself as a as a
product and the analogy that I use is to
find the sharpest arrow in one's quiver
and to use that over and over again
because life is short and and we're not
going to solve every problem we're not
going to learn every skill but what we
can do is kind of you know train our
phaser fire on the weakest part and the
board cube and and and make some make
some headway there in my case I would
say that that having a good broad litter
literacy of Science and Technology along
with an appreciation for for how one
must work with others and how working
with others generates ideas is is the is
sort of my my sharpest arrow I think the
the ability to communicate with with
individuals in the group not not just
what is their nest next experiment going
to be but how are they going to manage
their time to get through a period in
their life where they you know they're
not making a lot of money they live in a
in a too hot apartment that literally or
air-conditioning's literally banned you
know they they may be very insecure this
is probably the most
symmetric power dynamics they're ever
likely to experience regret the grad
student P I relationship I try to to be
to be as empathetic and gentle as I can
with that with that relationship because
I know how how tenuous it is from the
standpoint of the student so I I would
say that I would say that being able to
identify ones ones one skills outside of
the technical realm are you know in
indeed the the sort of the the inverse
or complement of what one would normally
consider from the outside to be
important and in an engineering or basic
science lab yeah I feel like scientists
in my field or in many other fields
almost exemplify kind of this inverse of
the you know Peter Principle of you know
you basically rise the level of your
incompetence I think where scientists do
is that they're assumed to be so
brilliant in engineers to just the raw
intellectual horsepowers as we say that
they can do anything and that includes
being a leader being a pie being a
professor I mean I never received any
training and being a professor in fact
some of the best education I had was
with when I was preparing to become a
certified flight instructor and there
you learn about the actual needs of the
student not just what house brilliant
you know the instructor needs to be but
also the needs of Maslow's hierarchy and
I know that's you know somewhat outdated
nowadays but they're they're you know
versions of it but I note that I was
never taught that I was never taught you
know here's how you become a professor
it was assumed that because I'm so
brilliant allegedly that I'll be good at
teaching but really the skills are could
not be more different and sometimes the
most educated most intelligent are
sometimes they make the worst teachers
yeah and yeah go ahead it's actually the
last the last sort of valley of death in
the academic progression where one stage
looks nothing like the stage before it
and the first one occurs between high
school and undergrad and the first thing
that I noticed is that once you start in
in college
you know people your TAS and your
instructors are you know they're not
viewing you as a number but they're kind
of viewing you as a number and a
position on the on the bell curve you
know for you know exam scores or
whatever the the next level up between
undergraduate and graduate education the
the modalities of training look nothing
alike and I think some degree of merging
the way we teach undergraduates with the
way we teach graduate students would
probably end up benefiting both
education at the bachelor's and PhD
level and then you know where it's
completely coursework based and then
it's completely experiencial in my
graduate school and and yet you know
you're still paying tuition or your
adviser is paying hey get your tuition
or whatever whatever we call tuition to
make it not tuition because it's illegal
here right exactly and then the last
transition between either PhD or postdoc
and then becoming you know a lab
director and that's not necessarily just
in academia but that could be any number
of industrial positions as well you know
there's no there's no similarity
whatsoever beyond you know the the two
hours per day that you actually had to
apply to actual research or to think
about formulation it's just in terms of
the job market I mean where else I would
say like imagine if it was like
incredibly easy to play triple-a
baseball again you know my Padres Jersey
but just like anybody could do it I
could do it I can't even you know throw
a pitch more than 20 miles an hour
probably but let's just say Bryan
Keating could be you know starting
pitcher I'm like what's the name of our
local triple-a team anyway there's a
team up in in Temecula it's like the
Padres formed but imagine if it was
super easy for me to get that job and
then imagine if it was basically
impossible to become a major league
baseball player like you go from being
you know basically a buyer's market
where it's very easy for me to get a job
as a you know as a pitcher or whatever
in triple-a in the very next level on
the academic rung is basic almost
forbidden nowadays
I mean I just had a postdoc get a get a
very prestigious professorship offer
from a top school in the UC system I'm
not gonna name him because he hasn't
announced officially I don't want to
congratulation cramp has hurt his or her
chances that actually negotiating for
the highest possible startup but but
it's it's quite it's quite and it was
like it made my day
I mean when I heard that I was like I
knew that there were 400 other
applicants to this job and in no other
place is you know I call it the academic
Hunger Games like you competed all these
different levels or all these
gatekeepers and and the rules of the
game change at every level and it's so
hard to keep in to keep things straight
as to you know by what rules
what organizing principles symmetry
principles shall I devote my energies as
an undergraduate versus a graduate soon
cuz you're right if it looks very
different the modalities of pedagogy
you're different I thought graduate
school would just be our version of
undergrad you know the homework problems
would be hard I knew that you know as an
undergrad there were problems I couldn't
answer cuz I just wasn't as smart as my
other you know classmates but I knew
that they could get it and somebody
could get it at graduate school you
don't even know the question let alone
the answer most of the time and that
level of uncertainty drives the human
mind put it in kind of a little bit to
distraction and may cause actual harm I
think emotionally that academics suffer
from higher rates of depression and and
even suicide I speak about that a little
bit in my book losing the Nobel Prize
one of my mentors as a postdoc committed
suicide and he was you know top notch of
his field at Cal Tech always perennial
II shortlisted to win a Nobel Prize in
Physics for great discoveries that he
made and and yet there and no one never
know why he why he did such a thing but
but and actually ironically his wife or
ex-wife Frances Arnold won the Nobel
Prize in Chemistry just a few years ago
and I'm wondering like you see this that
your mission in part at least is to
benefit the mental health of our very
cherished students absolutely and I
frequently get emails from students
thanking me for the material that I post
I have one
Giller talk on the word unconventional
is in scare quotes unconventional
careers for PhDs and they're called
unconventional by you know people like
us because a career outside of academia
for PhD is considered unconventional
even though that's 95 percent of PhD
holders and the system is the system is
the way that this the reason this
pyramid scheme kind of exists is because
of the funding structure we don't call
the thirty billion dollar NIH budget as
an educational you know isn't as
primarily consisting of educational
grants but really that's what it is the
vast majority of the thirty billion from
NIH or the seven seven and a half or
whatever it is billion from NSF most of
that is going toward toward training of
graduate students and we call them
research grants but really it's you know
they're they're educational grants and
we don't do a great job at preparing
PhDs for the the positions that that
that are actually open to them at least
you know by the arithmetic there are
just so many fantastic PhD researchers
who are not going to be employed as
tenure-track professors and what we need
to do is is bring in people from from
industry and consulting and policy and
government and show them the you know if
we're going to keep the funding
structure the way the way it is we have
to find a way to to open the doors to
positions outside of academia and
perhaps outside of stem focused industry
as well because these are very important
jobs being done by extremely smart
hard-working impactful individuals and
the exposure to those worlds is is not
not good at a university my my wife is a
good example she has the same academic
pedigree that I do she
did her she worked for a number of
startups after finishing her her postdoc
at Stanford she did her her MBA at the
rate eSchool of management at UCSD and
is now working in biotech and I would
say making a real difference on the on
the kovat response actually works in it
for one of the companies that has one of
the the largest market shares of Co
testing in the u.s. so this is this is a
way that somebody who you know who's
working in the on the business side of a
technology or of a biotechnology company
is making a much bigger impact frankly
than I ever will in my you know just in
the last three months the interact
hasn't been bigger but who even knows
you know what upstream marketing is we
don't teach that to we don't we think
it's you know advertise their upstream
USP I think multi-level marketing so I
can make a profit but exactly exactly
yeah or like upscale marketing oh so
it's like a Super Bowl ad no it's it's
nothing like that no yeah I had a
conversation with the patron of the
Symons Observatory Jim Simons who's had
success in three widely disparate fields
from pure mathematics to to running the
world some of the world's largest hedge
funds to running the war in the world's
largest philanthropic organizations
dedicated to pure not applied research
and he said you know one of the most
important attributes of a good scientist
is to be a Salesman not in they you know
sleazy cloying in a kind of way at Wow I
won't say used-car salesman because some
of them are faster mind but you get the
idea the stereotype is certainly has
some wide applicability but but it is a
skill that is incredibly under
appreciated and and and actually this is
part of my philosophy in the way I run
my group with my colleague professor kam
Arnold is we mandate that our students
spend a certain amount of time outside
their own discipline learning about
other branches not not of you know
engineering necessarily although that's
very important obviously for what we do
on a practical basis but but actually to
understand you know controversies and
other branches of astronomy that are
totally
related to the cosmology to the origin
of the universe that we do for our
day-to-day activities and even with in
cosmology to explore alternatives not
wacky things but explore like the the
ten reasons you should not believe in
the Big Bang just for example because I
think it sharpens the mind to really be
able to ant you know as we say you know
you should know what to say to a heretic
and in whatever religion or cult you're
a member of and in this case there's
there's reasons to that benefit the mind
by going against the grain of the
traditional orthodoxy and I think that's
an emblematic exactly as you said we
call it unconventional but really those
are the dominant you know kind of
attributes and skillsets and we just
don't teach them because we're
interested in making these you know
mushrooms or clones of ourselves and
because I think to give ourselves some
leeway we we don't get taught it
ourselves and you know where there's
there's you know there's an old saying
in in psychiatry that I learned from you
know dr. Judson Brewer and that's you
know victims victimized victims or yeah
basically we are the byproduct of the
system so it's gonna take people like
yourself to kind of break the mold that
look these are these are equally maybe
even more important and just to say that
is so shocking the problem of courses
that our older colleagues but might not
you know who are in the gatekeepers of
our advancement and we should point out
advancement doesn't stop when you're you
know merely you know when you become a
professor right in some ways it begins
and it begins anew the academic
hungergames running a little bit long on
time I want to respect your your
schedule I do want to just touch base on
one thing that I'm just very curious
about you and then we'll schedule for
the next episode if you'll come back in
the podcast or maybe we'll time it for a
couple weeks from now I want to talk
about your article and Sal about coping
and dealing with them promote education
using during kovat and your tools and
tactics because it looks like we're
going to be in for a long ride with
kovat unfortunately and then I want to
ask you some of the questions I asked of
all my guests these are kind of big
picture looking deep into the future
billions of years and then looking deep
into the past advice to your former self
so we'll leave that as a tea
or for everybody for part 2 down will
you come back on a part - I'd love to
so let me just conclude with a question
that I'm just very curious about if you
had to teach you know you had a
billboard or whatever and and you could
teach the most important thing in your
field in chemistry Chemical Engineering
nano engineering what would that thing
be what what is the most fundamental
result of nano engineering I remember
reading about this a book nano Kazem
what the heck is a guy's name you know
what I'm talking about right this is the
first popularization of nanotechnology
I'm thinking of pray by Michael Crichton
oh yes engines of creation yeah Eric
Drexler dad Drexler Drexler wrote at
nano khazin - yep that's right so these
are 20 30 year old works right what is
the most important thing that you wish
every human being that you meet you just
want to shake them what's the most
important thing in nano engineering I
have an answer it's a bit more of an
ensemble answer than a nanoscopic answer
but it's something that really struck me
recently and that's the importance of
energy dissipation and at the very small
scale so people think that the reason
that tape sticks to walls is because you
have very you know intimate bandar balls
adhesion between the glue molecules
which is really just a low glass
transition temperature polymer you know
attached to the porous surface really
what you're doing is you are you're
routing the goal of engineering and
adhesive is to route as many as much of
the mechanical work as possible into
molecular bond deformation so that it
goes there instead of separating the
interface with the material okay so
that's a bit of a boring thing but this
remember that next time I put a band I
don't want to so so dissipation is isn't
isn't not always like a bad thing like
like friction friction if there were no
if there was no energy dissipation and
the earth and the the interaction
between the soles of your shoes and the
earth you would just take one step and
then circle the globe right so so
dissipation in engineering is one of the
most important
the important aspects of engineering
science that we don't teach explicitly
you know we teach conservation of energy
in the first law of thermodynamics but
we don't say look this is really
important it has really bad and really
fantastic applications or consequences
so you know know where all of your
energy is going and engineer for your
energy to go where you want it to go
antastic yes again I'll tell that to my
kids when you're not letting enough
dissipation to take place at the
molecular level sunny
well Darren this has been so much fun we
might need to like to have our own
series even multiple lectures I want to
point people just while we have the time
now to your podcast Molecular podcasting
also your YouTube channel Darren Lupo me
that's Darren with two hours en and then
Li P OMI for those of you listening it's
really worth your time even if you're
not a scientist
you can replace succeeding in scientific
research in this playlist with anything
that you do it could be business
management anything where there's
responsibility a duty to communicate
complex ideas quanta in a quantitative
realm that will benefit you so I think
I'm encouraging my listeners my audience
to go out there and do that look into
Darren's research he does such
fascinating stuff it's too bad we didn't
get to do the Kyoto Prize ceremony stuff
together this year but hopefully it'll
be back on at some point in the future
and as I said I would really want to go
over this wonderful piece that you put
in in the journal Cell not too long ago
when I thought COBIT would be a passing
fancy
now now trends in chemistry published by
self so much give energy yes that's
right
I saw the link in to that in the notes
in the YouTube video and Darren this has
been such a pleasure I hope you have a
rest there restful rest of your week and
I hope we can catch up again maybe
sometime in a couple weeks
I hope so too and we'll certainly make
it happen thanks Bryan
thanks Darren